le secteur des pompes funèbres s'est
aussi adapté à la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus si les enterrements se font
désormais en tout petit comité des
cérémonies d'hommage pourront être
programmés après de confinement les
professionnels doivent eux se protéger
en s'équipant comme les soignants mais
dans une lettre lue au 19 mars adressée
au ministère de la santé des personnels
des pompes funèbres ont souligné le
manque de protection notamment de
masques de gel hydro alcoolique ou
encore de combinaisons on en parle
justement avec lambert avasin directeur
général de la plateforme d'obsèques en
ligne reposer ou monsieur ravasi bonjour
merci d'être en direct avec nous alors
je viens de le dire le personnel des
pompes funèbres décrit le manque de
moyens matériels tout comme le personnel
soignant
effectivement comme pour le personnel
soignant on sert entre les genres dans
les pharmacies et il faut reconnaître
que pour l'instant bavarde fatigué il
faut revoir dimas
tensionnelle pas plus que de réelles pas
de blouse et lynette également sa part
l'importance n'est donc on est obligé de
se débrouiller c'est un peu flatteur
entreprises la société chaque personne
c'est les boules parce que même pour se
procurer six équipes ont été faites
alors 1100 morts en france est-ce que
vous dans votre travail vous avez vous
avez senti cette augmentation du nombre
de décès dans le pays
quand même légère pour l'instant
l'augmentation est légère mais book
l'appartement des pierres qu'on puisse
en main on parle de déchets lieu dit el
milia également de l'esepac même si la
personne possédant également des
logiciels de musique du caractère des
pâtes savoir donc pour l'instant on sent
qu'on soit une légère augmentation du
travail que ça va augmenter dans le jura
monsieur ravasi merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous la liaison était très
mauvaise rappelle que vous êtes
directeur général de la plateforme
d'obsèques en ligne proposés aux merci
d'avoir été avec nous